hello everyone it's still only October
but as far as chess is concerned I'm
pretty sure 11 Ariana's is the man of
the year 2017 as human more tournaments
than any other talk Grandmaster in 2017
Plus not to mention he won the World Cup
and got married in the same week so
quite an achievement by the Armenian
Grandmaster this name he is playing
against the Ukrainian Grandmaster Andre
polo kitten and well it's it's as if the
game was played in in 1850 it's such a
romantic attack that well it's just
something everyone should see and well a
lot of people will say that you know
with chest chest 960 bughouse chest is a
really book is really bad for classical
chest
but as Ariane proves it doesn't seem to
be and Iranian even suggests that one
should play chess 960 and the bughouse
as well as it will really improve your
calculations so yeah with that being
said let's see this game Oregon has the
white pieces and the wall Oh kitten has
the black pieces we have d4 d5 c4 c6 the
Slav defense Knight to c3 Knight to f6
III g6 Knight to f3 Bishop to g7
transposing into the groom fell defense
h3 valo keeping castles Bishop to d3 and
the Bishop to e6 and this is the wall
and this is somewhat a weird development
of this light square bishop so Aragon
goes for
Knight to g5 immediately attacks the
bishop we have Bishop to a5 not allowing
the exchange to happen on e 6 so we have
Bishop captures on f6 on f5 sorry G
captures on f5 and Queen to b3 with a
with a triple attack on this d5 pawn and
also with an attack on this b7 pawn so
Queen to b6 defending both threats as
now Volo kitten is threatening to
exchange Queens are in place Queen to c2
not allowing the exchange we have 6 and
well a lot of players will go for
like me three here followed by Bishop to
b2 or maybe if you're if you'd like to
keep it safe maybe castling and then
well depending on what black plays
continued the game but onion in this
position decided to go for g4 a very a
very aggressive approach we have a ch3
h6 sorry kicking the night away from g5
and Knight to f3 and we have F captures
on g4 we have H captures on g4 and now
eleven is offering this g4 pawn in
exchange for four playing rock to g1
this could be dangerous for black but
the Ukrainian Grandmaster is not afraid
he plays Knight captures on g4 and in
fact this position is okay for black
this is well white will get some
activity but not nothing too much but
nothing black can handle efore by 11 we
have d captures on c4 and now he 5 and
it does seem like white is really going
for a very nice attack here but again
with precise play black can handle this
and well okay team plays Knight to d7
and even this move wasn't wasn't really
that easy to find because well on one
hand you do have to develop on the other
hand worse this not going it can go to
f6 it can go to c5 I can't go to be 60
the queen is blocking it so you know
although blacks position is fine it's
not that easy to find the moves Bishop
to e3 and we have f5 queenside castle by
11 and we have c5 black wants to under
both his pawns open up the D file and
well it would be very nice if he could
exchange some rooks then then he would
be perfectly fine but 11 isn't
interested in this he plays d5 keeping
these pawns closed here
sorry doubled and well here with a move
like rook a to e 8 volt eating could
continue playing this game and it would
be perfectly fine
but he decided to play f4 I would an
attack on this Bishop would the idea
well
we move for the bishop is Bishop to d2
and now Knight captures an F two forks
both of these rooks but the problem is
after F 411 goes for Knight to g5 he
lives leaves his bishop here attacked
and also offers offers his knight and g5
and this is where Ireland's great attack
begins the threat of course is Queen to
h7 and this comes with checkmate so the
knight has to be captured H captures on
g5 was played but this allows Queen to
h7 with check King to f7 and RM plays a
night Stewie for ending well this very
nice night into the attack and well here
we have e captures on d5 and if you
played something like Knight captures on
e5 you'd get D captures on e6 with check
you can capture with the Queen because
of Knight to g5 with the Royal fork so
after King to e6 recapturing the Knight
captures and g5 King to f6 and now
Bishop captures on c5 would an attack on
the Queen and the rook and white is
completely winning here you can't
capture the bishop because you get
Knight to e4 again for King the king and
the Queen so after this Knight to e4
volt heating plate he captures on d5
this is the best move and well again
here there are there are a couple of
good options for example Knight captures
on g5 would check would be a good option
Queen to h5 check would be a good option
rook captures on d5 would be a good
option but Aragon decides to play this
game in a very romantic style and he
plays v6 with check immediately and well
okay you can't really capture the pawn
with the Queen
you get knife characters on g5 winning
the Queen so after each six trick you
don't really want to go back with the
king I mean you just lose a piece so
King captures on e6 was played and here
we have a well it's a capture but also
it's a quiet move Queen captures on g7
allowing black now to decide what the
play
and here mr. vole Oh kitten played
Knight G to f6 which is in fact the
strongest move if you play something
like D captures on e4 you get Queen
captures on d7 with check King to f6 and
rook to d6 winning the Queen and after
Queen to g7 if you play something like F
captures on e3 if you grab this bishop
well then knife capture son g5 comes
King to d6 and now rook captures on d5 a
very nasty idea as you can't really
capture this rook if King captures then
you get rook to d1 check at phoenix e6
and Queen captures and see on d7 with
checkmate
very nice so after this rook captures on
d5 move
well okay team would probably could will
not be able to capture he would have to
play something like King to c7 and now
comes rock captures on d7 would check
King to c6 and now rook to d6 and well
this rook cannot be captured as you get
the same checkmate as before
so after this Queen to g7 we have Knight
G to f6 and in fact this is the
strongest move here R&M plays Bishop
captures on c5 and well what do you play
here
well Knight captures on c5 was played
and this again is the best move here
Arjun played Knight captures and c5
again with check and this is well one of
the critical positions in the game would
move like king to d6 while kidding could
still continue to play this game but he
decided to grab this night with Queen
captures and c5 and this allowed this
allows the rook to come into game with
tempo rook DT one with check we have
King to f5 but well pretty much any
other move isn't good either
for example if we block with Knight to
e4 you get rook to h6 check rook has to
defend now rook captures would check
that the knight is pinned cannot
recapture
King 3:5 now Rock f7 discovery from the
Queen King goes to d6 and our Queen h6
check King has to go back and out Queen
to f6 with checkmate again the knight is
pinned
so after this rook DT one with check of
all hitting play King to f5 and well
this is the greatest position in this
game and I would really like you to
study this position imagine you are
playing this game and well there is a
little time on the clock you're on the
attack and you have to find the the
winning move and there is only one move
that is winning that really allows
Aragon to continue his attack so if you
if you feel like you know feel free to
pause the video and well be a great
attack or like 11:00 and find the
winning move okay I will give it a few
more seconds for those of you who didn't
pause the video okay if any of you found
this move congratulations you're you're
a natural attacker and for those of you
who want to see Elevens brilliancy in
this position I'm gonna plate rook to h5
well you're attacking you do have to
give up material to continue the attack
but the rook of course cannot be
captured but it is the only move the
threat of course is Queen captures on g5
wood checkmate if you try and walk this
with rook the g8 and then simply rook
captures and g5 is again checkmate and
well valo kidding sorry what we can't
ride with Knight captures and h5 as
there really isn't any other move you
can play here but this allows a forced
checkmate in seven moves and Aragon
finds the exact the exact combination
rook to e5 would check only move King to
g4 now Queen captures on g5 would check
King to f3 Queen captures a night on h5
would check King captures an f2 now
Queen to e2 with check and in this
position the Ukrainian Grandmaster and
revolt kitten resigned the game as what
would follow is what King to g3 for
example rock to g5 with check
kinked h4 and queen g4 with checkmate
but of course this wasn't necessary but
you know it would have been nice if the
Ukrainian Grandmaster allowed this as
the lemon played such a spectacular
romantic again if I do say so myself
so yeah definitely a beautiful game it's
like I said it's as if it was played in
well not the opening but the middle game
as it as if it was played in the 1850s
so yeah I do hope you enjoyed this game
and well as usual you can check - all my
previous videos here I think all for
watching and I will see you soon